[Applaus]
und dann gab es noch was womit wirklich
gar keiner mehr gerechnet hat gute
Nachrichten ja in Polen fliegt wohl die
pisspartei aus der Regierung die
Opposition angeführt von Donald Tusk
übernimmt nach allem was wir heute
wissen großes Aufatmen in Europa großes
Aufatmen denn die rechte Welle macht
zumindest mal ein Päuschen wie war das
möglich eine sehr Wache polnische
Zivilgesellschaft hatte nach 8 Jahren
unter der pisspartei schlicht die
Schnauze voll dafür sprechen auch die
gut 74% Wahlbeteiligung und mit Jaroslav
Kinski will halt keiner mehr regieren
nicht mal mehr die Bauernpartei dabe hat
er die so schön
umworben es gibt keine bitte
entschuldigen Sie die Ausdrucksweise
keine größere Dummheit als zu sagen dass
die irgendwelche Kompetenzen haben das
sind Banausen und
Faulpelze Kinskis Problem als er heute
in die pparteizentrale fährt er braucht
einen koalitionsp aber die Faulpelze von
der Bauernpartei haben nicht völlig
überraschend
abgesagt siehst du die faulen Bauern
sind sogar zu faul zum Regieren stellt
dir das mal vor ja wunderbares Happy End
also nach einem sehr sehr aggressiven
piss Wahlkampf Donald Tusk wird
wahrscheinlich wieder Premierminister
und dann ist Polen aber offen Freunde
bzw endlich wieder weltoffen
andererseits ist die piss natürlich
immer noch stärkste Partei ich frage
mich gerade könnten die ihren Nachfolger
noch irgendwelche Steine in den Weg
legen ha wer könnte sowas wissen gut mit
den Polen ist es ja so wenn ein Pole und
da kann er gar nichts dafür ein neues
Auto sieht es muss ihm nicht mal
gefallen hauptsache es ist neu das ZDF
stellt fest alles was Richard David
Brecht vielleicht gerade sagen wollte
ist wahrscheinlich komplett falsch in
diesem Sinne sorry und Grüße aus
Mainz ja von mir auch ich habe es in der
Zwischenzeit mal selber gegoogelt
tatsächlich kann der pissna Präsident
duda die Regierungsbildung in Warschau
noch verzögern wenn es blöd läuft aber
gut jetzt freuen wir uns erstmal über
das Ergebnis und über die polnischen
Frauen ja es sind mehr Frauen deutlich
mehr Frauen als Männer zur Wahl gegangen
und die wollten katchinski
offensichtlich nicht mehr haben ne ist
übrigens auch kein Wunder kann ich Ihnen
sagen denn 2020 hat ein von der piss
politisch besetztes Gericht Abtreibung
in Polen fast unmöglich gemacht und
seitdem gehen ihm ar die Frauen auf dem
Land von der Fahne also jetzt mal
abgesehen von einigen sehr katholischen
Einzelfällen früer hat man gesagt man
sollte eben einfach schlafen und nicht
so oft diese Dinge tun wisen schon aber
heutzutage herrscht so eine
Zügellosigkeit dass man alles mögliche
macht und jede Sekunde schwanger
wird wer wird denn schwanger in einer
Sekunde 20 Minuten um mir die Socken
auszuziehen so damit endet also erstmal
katinskis Versuch sein Land in eine
Autokratie umzubauen viel hat nicht mehr
gefehlt vielleicht hatten die Leute von
ihm auch die Nase voll weil sie gemerkt
haben wie heuchlerisch das ist gegen
Migranten zu hetzen und sie gleichzeitig
heimlich zum Arbeiten reinzulassen da
helfen dann auch keine antideutschen
pisspots mehr wie dieser legendäre hier
wo der deutsche Botschafter Kinski
anruft und befieht das Rentenalter in
pol wieder auf 67 hochzusetzen und er
dann so volloisch Berlin hat mir gar
nichts zu sagen dann legt er eiskalt
auf guckt da noch ganz cool ohne Tschüss
zu sagen super und die Anrufe die er
jetzt nach der Wahl kriegt die sind ja
sogar noch unverschämter vor allem die
von seiner Frau hallo hallo Schatz ich
ma gerade ein kreuzwrzel ehemaliger
möchte gern Autokrat von Polen der bald
ganz viel Tagesfreizeit hat neu
Buchstaben endet auf cinski hast du eine
Idee ich weiß es katinski
war zu einfach war zu einfach ja das
deutschen bching hat diesmal nicht so
gezogen bei dieser Wahl dabei haben die
wirklich alles gegeben Donald Tusk wurde
quasi als Deutscher Geheimagent
verteufelt in einer Tour ja
Befehlsempfänger Befehlsempfänger der
Europäischen Union was ja bekanntlich
nur ein anderes Wort für Deutschland ist
so aber was war das Geheimnis seiner
Kampagne was war sein Erfolgsgeheimnis
ich kann es ihnen sagen liebe ja das war
ihr Symbol mit einem Herz gegen Hetze
das können wir uns vielleicht mal merken
im Umgang mit unseren eigenen Populisten
mehr liebewagen verstehen sie Tusk hat
sich eben nicht in Schlammschlachten von
denen locken lassen und alle
Provokationen ignoriert eigene positive
Akzente gesetzt was ich immer sage ne
gute Nachrichten tun einfach gut gerade
in diesen
Zeiten nur noch gute Nachrichten mit
Friedemann
Weise gute Nachricht zuerst es gibt noch
gute Nachrichten man muss sie nur finden
hier z.B Richter erlaubt in die Ostsee
pinkeln eine
riesenerleichterung nicht nur für uns
auch für die Fische die standen ja
bisher ständig mit einer Flosse im
Knast oder hier der schwerste Kürbis
Europas kommt aus
Deutschland ein Student aus Bayern hat
die Europameisterschaften im
kürbiswiegen gewonnen freut er sich
richtig kann ich sehr gut verstehen ich
hatte als Student auch keine Freunde
derer ebenfalls Grund zur Freude hat ist
Helmut aus Gelsenkirchen Helmut war
lange Zeit zu dick konnte kaum noch
laufen mit diesem Spezial Rollbrett
musste er fast zwei Jahre lang
unterstützt werden eine Therapie und
Ernährungsumstellung haben geholfen
deswegen marschiert Helmut jetzt wieder
selbständig durch den Zoo als wäre nie
was gewesen das Beste an der Meldung
natürlich Helmuts Rollbrett ist jetzt
frei wenn sie auch zu dick sind und
Kassenpatient einfach mal in
Gelsenkirchen
vorbeischauen aber um die guten
Nachrichten zu finden muss man sich
leider auch durch die schlechten Quellen
und hier ist die Frage was mute ich mir
zu aber auch was mute ich den Kindern zu
mit meiner Tochter gucke ich ganz
bewusst die Tagesschau allerdings
schneide ich vorher die ganz schlimmen
Nachrichten
guten Tag meine Damen und Herren
willkommen zur Tagesschau auf
Wiedersehen das spart übrigens auch viel
Zeit die Kinder konsumieren Nachrichten
ja sowieso fast nur noch in den sozialen
Medien und da werden die Inhalte ja zum
Glück alle kindgerecht
dargestellt hier ist das erste deutsche
Fernsehen auf Mastodon auf
Mastodon schon wieder eine Droge von der
ich noch nie gehört habe ich finde die
Sender haben ja auch eine Verantwortung
manchmal wundert da schon wen die so vor
die Kamera lassen und in welchem Zustand
ich kenne mich hier nicht aus und
brauche ihre Hilfe können Sie mir sagen
wie ich zum Bahnhof
komme das kann ich leider nicht ich
wurde auch nur hier abgestellt und lese
den telepromp davor zum Glück gibt es
aber auch Menschen die sich
professionell mit dem Thema
nachrichtenkonsum befassen und konkrete
Ratschläge geben Christina Bernt
empfiehlt auch Nachrichten bewusst zu
konsumieren z.B zweimal am Tag und dann
Pausen
einzulegen so wird's gemacht nur zweimal
am Tag Nachrichten konsumieren ich
empfehle morgens und abends jeweils vor
dem kotzen und wenn das alles nichts
hilft schauen sie einfach alte
Nachrichten aus einer Zeit als die Welt
noch in Ordnung war hier Tagesschau vor
20 Jahren die israelische Armee hat
heute mehrere gezielte Angriffe gegen
militante Palästinenser im Gazastreifen
geflogen oh nein das funktioniert wohl
nicht schnell gab's nicht noch eine gute
Nachricht ach doch Nachwuchs bei den
teletubbiys ja ist das nicht schön die
Sonne der teletubbiis ist schwanger
gratuliere ich frage mich ja wer der
Vater
ist ich hab's geahnt in diesem Sinne
winke
winke nur noch gute Nachrichten miten
Weise so Aufnahme
hallo dies ist die automatische endcard
von Oliver Welke und der heute show
leider ist das Video schon vorbei ihr
könnt den Kanal allerdings gerne
abonnieren und ein weiteres Video
anschauen vielen Dank so müsste jetzt
für immer reichen